[Música]
bienvenidos una semana más a medio
ambiente en france 24 podríamos decir
que en el mundo de las finanzas hay dos
tipos de proyectos de infraestructura
los que requieren de menos de cinco
millones de dólares que suelen salir de
los presupuestos de las autoridades
locales y los que requieren de más de 75
millones de dólares que suelen estar a
cargo de los grandes bancos de
desarrollo o bancos privados a los que
no les compensa invertir en proyectos de
menor envergadura pero qué pasa entonces
con los proyectos de rango medio pues
que pertenecen a una categoría en la que
hay un vacío de financiamiento y es aquí
donde entra el tema ambiental ya que la
mayoría de proyectos de movilidad limpia
energías renovables manejo de residuos o
saneamiento pertenece a ese rango de
inversión que no pueden permitirse los
gobiernos locales ni les interesa a los
grandes bancos para rellenar ese hueco
monetario surgió el nuevo fondo sur
nacional para el clima un vehículo de
financiamiento mixto que involucra al
sector público y al privado el objetivo
de este fondo es alcanzar los 750
millones de dólares para infraestructura
de mitigación y adaptación al cambio
climático
ahora solo están asegurados 150 millones
que provienen del fondo verde para el
clima este innovador mecanismo está
apoyado por un consorcio formado por el
gestor de fondos pegasus capital por la
unión internacional para la conservación
de la naturaleza que provee asistencia
técnica por la certificación y
verificación de gaulle standard que se
asegura de que el impacto positivo es
real y no es sólo mercadeo por el banco
privado francés bnp paribas que buscará
capital entre sus clientes privados para
surtir los 600 millones de dólares que
faltan y todo está coordinado por ere 20
regiones de acción climática una
organización no gubernamental creada en
2011 por el ex gobernador de california
arnold schwarzenegger que coordina la
comunicación de los proyectos entre tres
sectores las autoridades locales los
actores privados y los inversores la
totalidad de este fondo sur nacional
como su nombre bien indica está dirigida
a apoyar a las autoridades locales y
regionales para lograr desarrollar
proyectos de infraestructura de alto
impacto social y ambiental pude
entrevistar al gestor nut al director
ejecutivo de r20 que nos habló de por
qué
gobiernos subnacionales son claves en la
lucha contra el cambio climático
las autoridades locales están mejor
situadas para responder a los retos del
cambio climático
addison tráiler al blog con la beldad
mayonesa es a este nivel a nivel
descentralizado al nivel local que los
alcaldes y gobernadores pueden
desarrollar proyectos de movilidad en
sus ciudades
es decir transporte limpios distrae
verdad fija en energía y chang yong lim
ding también a este nivel podemos
construir edificios que sean
enérgicamente eficientes iluminación led
podemos conseguir procesos de
recolección y revalorización de los
desechos con bajas emisiones y
resilientes al clima además podemos
implementar soluciones verdes en cuanto
a saneamiento
podemos también crear proyectos
descentralizados de energías renovables
'fast track' y este tipo de
infraestructura está normalmente en un
rango de inversión de entre 5 y 75
millones de dólares así que de un solo
golpe podemos tener un impacto en varios
sectores impacto social e impacto
ambiental pero también un impacto de
inversión que beneficia al bienestar de
la población
world of the population lo colectado
bichi con semana santa las autoridades
locales son responsables del 70% de la
mitigación y de la adaptación al cambio
climático y por eso creamos este fondo
porque las autoridades subnacionales a
pesar de que tienen el mayor potencial
en cuanto a soluciones verdes no tienen
acceso a los mecanismos financieros
tradicionales adicional find mccann y
seed durante la cumbre climática cop 16
de cancún en 2010 los países más
industrializados llegaron al compromiso
de invertir 100 mil millones de dólares
cada año hasta 2020 para ayudar a países
en desarrollo algo que no se cumplió así
que 750 millones parecen una nimiedad
por eso no tal espera que con este
primer fondo se abra un nuevo tipo de
mercado con unas herramientas que le den
confianza al sector privado para
invertir en la lucha contra el cambio
climático y esta nueva estructura se
discutirá durante la cumbre climática de
glasgow que se celebra en noviembre
donde esperan demostrar que se pueden
crear asociaciones entre diferente
partes que no suelen interactuar con la
idea de replicar a gran escala este
fondo y así alcanzar los cinco mil
millones de dólares
el francés dice ser optimista y asegura
que está habiendo un cambio en el mundo
de las finanzas que segundo tal cada vez
tiene mayor apetito por la inversión
sostenible estos proyectos de
infraestructura están dirigidos a países
en desarrollo y pequeñas naciones
insulares en américa latina son 10 los
países que se beneficiarán aunque tanto
r20 como cc 35 que es la coalición de
ciudades capitales de las américas
frente al cambio climático están en
conversaciones para que se creen dos
fondos sus nacionales exclusivos para el
continente uno dedicado a los países
caribeños y otro para el resto de los
países latinoamericanos ya de cara a la
cob 26 cristo frutal quiere lanzar un
mensaje de unidad frente al reto global
y compartido que suponen el
calentamiento global y el cambio
climático
si queremos lograr los objetivos del
acuerdo de parís tenemos que trabajar en
asociación no de manera aislada
construir alianzas con las
autoridades locales la sociedad civil el
sector privado los inversores y las
naciones unidas es extremadamente
importante
y existen muy importantes
we know that it is complex
sabemos que es complejo que cada uno de
estos actores tiene normas y
regulaciones diferentes culturas
diferentes y provienen de contextos
distintos pero como siempre he dicho
podemos ir más deprisa solos pero juntos
somos más fuertes para llegar más lejos
y ser más poderosos y hasta tuvo long
ánimo para ver fútbol así finalizamos
esta semana sigan en france24
[Música]